foreign
[Music]
binsberg and a finance professor at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania and I'm Jonathan Burke a
financial professor at The Graduate
School of Business at Stanford
University and this is the all else
equal podcast
welcome back everybody today is going to
be our last episode before we go into
our summer schedule so we'll go not into
a bi-weekly schedule but rather a
monthly schedule instead and Jonathan I
think we've had a fantastic year it's
been such a good year in so many ways
our listenership has grown so much our
subscribers have grown so much and we've
got two Awards this year the signal
Awards and the American writing Awards I
really think that this year could not
have gone better I agree Jules I'm in
many way I was very surprised we have
almost 300 000 listens and something
like 15 000 subscribers you know I'm
very surprised and you know it's very
enjoyable to go to conferences and have
people tell you that they've been
listening to the podcast and what they
liked about the podcast and so fittingly
I think we're gonna end on a high note
for the season on a topic that I think
our listeners will be very interested in
which is two important questions the
first one how do you become a CEO so
what are the characteristics of the
people that become CEOs what do their
CVS look like and what is the quickest
way to become a CEO of a company and
then secondly how are CEOs compensated
and is that fair yeah and I think these
are subjects that you and I have often
been in discussions with with a mutual
friend of ours Dirk yenter who's a
professor of Finance at the London
School of economics and I would say a
world expert on CEOs and so the two of
us thought it'd be great just to do a
podcast where we have a conversation
with Dirk and just talk about many of
the issues the CEO that he has found in
his research so with that in mind Dirk
welcome to the show thank you very much
for having me it's a pleasure seeing
both of you it's really great to have
you Dirk thanks so much for taking the
time to speak with us so Dirk people
have a fascination of CEOs because
they're wealthy people but here our
focus is different tell us why do CEOs
matter for the world and why should we
be interested in CEOs this is a really
great question I am completely with you
we're not interested in CEOs because
they're rich or in the media anything
like that as an academic we're not
groupies for rich people in fact in many
ways if you could run the world without
them we would probably all be quite
happy with that but by now there's
really a lot of evidence that CEOs do
matter and it just starts with the very
simple observation that when a CEO
changes or when a company changes its
CEO the company tends to change a lot
both in terms of firm behavior and in
terms of firm performance now this is a
little bit difficult to interpret right
and we know that because it might just
be that the firm needs a change the
board desires The Firm to change and in
that process also brings in a new CEO
and probably the firms that need to
change the most going to bring in an
outside CEO then it's just going to be
really really really difficult to figure
out whether the changes we see are
actually due to the CEO are caused by
the CEO are just part of some sort of
bigger change program going on now
having said about this the sheer fact
that board members directors experienced
Executives feel like they have to bring
in a new Co whenever a company really
needs to change kind of tells you
something it would be really odd if this
was all some kind of weird cargo card
some kind of weird delusion that oh we
need to bring in somebody new to change
the firm right these very experienced
Executives this very experienced
directors are convinced that CEOs are
really really important another piece of
evidence here is that really over the
last 10 15 years a really wonderful
literature has sprung up there does
surveys of of companies and really
figures out what the management
processes inside these companies are so
management processes are things like
lean management and permanent or
Perpetual performance improvements
reporting requirements documentation on
and on and on and there's an incredibly
strong correlation between having these
structured management processes and
Company performance so really suggesting
that management is a thing right
management matters management isn't just
some people making stuff up this is
actually a process this is a technology
and it really differs across companies
now some research we've done which I
think is really interesting even being
slightly distasteful is looking at
situations where CEOs die in office now
this is obviously a terrible situation
it's tragic but from a research
perspective it's also really interesting
because now we have a CEO change but
it's one that's not desired by the board
of directors so it's not a situation
where the board of directors says oh the
company needs to change change let's
bring a new CEO in fact out of the ideal
experiment is one where the board wakes
up in the morning and says oh my God
we've just lost our Co this is horrible
this is terrible now we need to find a
new one and even in these situations we
do find that companies change a lot and
interestingly not in a specific
directions they just change some change
their leverage upwards some change it
downwards some increase their sales
growth some lowers their sales growth
and on and on and on so really just
saying that CEOs matter and different
CEOs do things differently probably most
interestingly for about 20 25 of
companies and to be clear we are talking
about large publicly traded companies
here for about 20 25 percent of
companies the stock price reaction to a
CEO death is positive suggesting that
shareholders are actually put it bluntly
kind of happy that the CEO died or at
least believe that the company is worth
more after the CEO died hopefully
they're not happy about it but so
certainly they do view the company as
more valuable after the CEO has died and
we also then see that subsequent
operating performance tends to improve
so this suggests that those companies
did not have the right CEO before so the
CEO deaths in some sense gives them an
opportunity to rematch find another one
find a better replacement and try again
which for me as a governance person is a
pretty strong indictment of the board of
directors basically saying you didn't do
your job before you had the wrong person
in office you needed to see your death
to finally do your job and go out and
find a better CEO something you should
have just done by yourself I mean so
summarizing all of that I think by now
there's just a lot of evidence that CEOs
really really do matter for what
companies do and for how well they
perform
fantastic thank you Dirk so a lot of our
listeners are senior Executives at firms
and so maybe you as an expert on CEOs if
you have to give them any advice what
are the sorts of things that CEOs need
to have as characteristics how do you
become a CEO at a company can you help
them out with that and that's another
really fantastic question so let me
start by talking a little bit about a
recent study we did where we did the
simplest thing possible we just looked
at all the new CEOs hired by S P 500
companies in the last 30 years and we
just wanted to see the background of
those CEOs and probably the most
important result you're the most
surprising results to us at least was
the absolute dominance of insiders so
there's this view that there is this
vibrant market for managerial Talent out
there that companies are competing with
each other for talent and are chasing
each other's employees hiring their top
Executives away the war for Talent now
this may well be true below Co level but
the moment we hit the co level think
large public companies CEOs it's just
plainly isn't true so a few numbers more
than 70 percent of all new S P 500 CEOs
are simply promoted internally so you
just take your number two or your number
three guy or one of your division hats
and you promote her to be the next CEO
now look at the remaining 30 about 10
percentage points of those so another 10
of all new CEO hires yes they aren't
current employees but they're former
Executives of the same company or
current or former board members so we
had to stood together and we have 80 to
81 percent I think was about 81 in our
sample 81 percent of new S P 500 COs in
the last 30 years were effectively
insiders to the company now in many ways
this immediately tells you that it's not
a very vibrant market right because the
moment you look predominantly inside the
company you look looking at two or three
candidates you're not looking at some
big pool of managerial Talent out there
you're trying to hire interestingly
enough now focusing in on these 19
Outsiders right so we have 19 of them
who are actually genuine Outsiders to
the firm more than half of them are
current from our co-workers after hiring
firms directors so let me just say this
very clearly even when the board of
directors decides all right we're not
find an Insider we like let's go for an
outsider more than half the time they go
for somebody is they personally know
really really well because they have
actually worked with that person
so then you add all of that together and
we have set more than 90 of all new S P
500 CEOs are either current or former
employees current or former board
members or co-workers of the firm's
directors another interesting one
Speaking of this sort of view of the
world where companies are chasing each
other's top executive Talent less than
three percent of new Co hires are
poached away from other companies from
the CEO position so less than three
percent of the new hires are current
CEOs of other companies so this idea
that they're trying to snatch away each
other CEOs it's just not in the data it
almost never ever happens and by the way
in the rare circumstances that it
happens the company doing the poaching
doing the snatching away it tends to be
four to five times larger than the
company from which they're hiring right
so this idea is that oh you're kind of
going to companies are just a bit
smaller your competitor you're snatching
away their CEO forget about it
absolutely not happening you're going to
a company that's way smaller and you
usually do that when you're in a bit of
a crisis situation right when you're
just desperately for some outside talent
and then you're basically stealing a
much much smaller Company CEO all of
that sort of suggests first of all that
a lot of sort of frictions as the
economists say in this market but also
very importantly to finally get back to
your question when we're thinking about
how to become a CEO it means you got to
become CEO in the company in which you
are an executive or to put it a little
bit more constructively you want to join
the company in which you will become a
CEO in which you are trying to become a
CEO at least five ideally 10 years
before you're ready for that next step
before you're ready to be promoted to
CEO and to make it a bit more practical
for our audience here if you just look
at the CVS of the people who actually
then become CEOs in the end there has
been a big shift in the last 50 years so
let me stereotype 50 years ago 10
typical CEO would join a company out of
college typically an engineering degree
almost inevitably a man coming with an
engineering degree out of a decent but
often not great college but joined a
company and then work his or her way up
through the company ranks for the next
30 or 40 years and then at age 58 on
average would be promoted to be the CEO
one company lots of knowledge about that
company but really very little knowledge
about anything else modern CEO sort of
2020 CEO 2023 CEO looks completely
different fortunately we got a bit more
gender diversity but it's still
predominantly male unfortunately but
arguably more interestingly typical
cocvz days is obviously still a college
degree more so than 50 years ago I
should say but probably college degree
less engineering than before but still
quite a bit and then a first drop which
came in a bank it can be in a
manufacturing Industrial company it can
be in a consulting company then probably
in MBA then probably at least one or two
other companies before joining the
company in which he or she will finally
be the CEO and having worked in a range
of functions across Finance operations
sales
etc etc etc so much more broadly
educated much more broadly trained what
we in the management literature call
General managerial skill so if you sort
of want to summarize this in buzzwords
well what people have been saying is
that we've had this shift from firm
specific skills where you know a ton
about one firm but not much else to
General managerial skills sort of the
modern CEO is capable of running a whole
range of companies so if you want to be
a CEO that's kind of what you need to do
build up this broad portfolio of skills
but then and that's sort of the new
insight here join the company in which
you want to be a CEO five to ten years
before that promotion so if you're in a
company right now in which you don't
think you have a clean shot at becoming
the CEO is that because there are people
ahead of you in the packing order or
because you just have a new CEO is going
to stay for another 15 years get out
right don't just sit there as a
department head or divisional hat and
hope somebody from the outside is going
to come and hire you as a CEO it's not
going to happen that's really not in the
data you got to go out you got to get
yourself hired right now as a divisional
head or president or Chief Operating
Officer and then you have a clean shot
at being internally promoted so does
that also then mean that if there's not
this market for CEOs that most people
are only CEO of only one company or are
people CEOs of multiple companies still
it's the vast majority this is another
great one we were still doing work on
this I should say but based on
everything I know and everything I've
seen the vast majority of CEOs are only
CEO of one company the Johnson means the
notion of if you have still massive
career concerns if you're a CEO because
you want to become the CEO of a larger
company afterwards a lot of people are
talking about that we looked for it in
the data we actually wanted to write
about that and frankly we were
disappointed because it simply doesn't
seem to be a thing for the vast majority
of CEOs typically you're going to be the
CEO of one and only one company and how
common is the Steve Jobs route where you
start a company you sell the company you
say that's it well Steve Jobs was kicked
out but generally you say that's it I'm
out of here and then the company grows
does badly and then you come back as CEO
yes no this is a really really good
point we do see quite a lot of that it
was part of the numbers I rattled down
very quickly earlier I mean if you look
at the external highest about a third of
them are X Executives current or from
abroad members right and there's a lot
of overlap obviously between these two
categories because at these Executives
quite a few of them are currently on the
board and you're exactly right you
usually bring those in in a crisis
situation which again for Us corporate
governance types trying to understand
what companies are doing and why they're
doing it it's genuinely interesting
because it says you are in a crisis your
current management team may not have
done particularly great you don't like
them you're not going to promote
internally so you're trying to go
external but you're not going to that
big managerial labor market I mean
you're an S P 500 company you would be
hiring a lot of Executives from a lot of
companies out there what do you do you
go back to your former CEO and it
doesn't even need to be former CEO
sometimes it's a former president a
former Chief Operating Officer again
suggesting especially in a tough
situation in a crisis situation the
board goes after somebody who either
knows the company already really really
well or who they know really really well
right and this is exactly one of these
things that we're trying to figure out
right now in our research which one of
these two factors is it right is it
about these firm specific skills so we
want somebody who knows the company
really well or is it about us the
directors would like to hire somebody
who we know really really well and who
we know we can trust but yes that's
exactly what you do you go to informal
Insider
so Dirk I have this expression which is
leadership is everything and I really
believe it I think without that there
really is nothing else that you could
take mediocre workers with a great
leader and produce an outstanding firm
and outstanding workers the poor leader
and you have trouble on your hands so
with that in mind the decision to hire
CEO is a hugely important decision so
what interpretation of the fact that
CEOs are generally internal hires is
because it's such an important decision
you really have to restrict yourself to
people you know yeah and so therefore
it's an optional thing to do and I know
there is a literature out there that has
a different view that there's really
just people hiring their bodies which do
you think it is this is many ways the
billion dollar I guess at this point
should update the trillion dollar
question all right
and I agree with you leadership is
incredibly important right and whenever
people say oh it's not we don't really
think it's important because gee when
one of those CEO leaves the next guy
comes in and doesn't do things all that
differently my reaction is always just
let me run Apple for five years trust me
you will see a difference
a little bit like saying look if you
kick out the goalie sorry for the
American audiences might not work very
well if you're kicking out the goalie of
a football team by which I mean a soccer
team when you kick out the goalie of a
professional football team nothing much
happens because they're just bring in
another one right and he's not even out
here she's not even on that much worse
and again it's the same story just let
me go into that goal for a while and you
will see a genuine difference right yes
we are replacing one extremist guilt
well-matched person but as another
extremely skilled well-matched person
and because it's so important that job
is done very very carefully and very
very well there's a lot of input and a
lot of thought so then as a result you
don't see these absolutely massive
shifts which is why we have to look at
things like people dying in office to
actually see some interesting action but
more concretely to your question right
in many ways why do boards do what they
do right why do they focus so much on
the Insiders why don't they use that
managerial Talent marketers that manage
your labor market a lot more one story
is again those firm specific skills that
firm specific knowledge right so knowing
the company its culture its processes
its people having a network of people
inside the company who you know are good
right that's incredibly crucial who you
know you can promote who you can draw on
who you can get information from that is
incredibly important if you want to run
an organization an incredibly difficult
to replicate for an outsider if you've
been there for five or ten years you
have your people you have your network
who knows good and who's bad you trust
people you know who you can trust people
know they can trust you and that's an
incredible basis for leadership it's a
really really good reason to go for an
Insider no here's another one we as
economists we do talk a lot about
adverse selection right and you as
Financial economists think about that
all the time it's a really big deal in
financial markets you're always worried
that the party you're trading with on
the other side has more information than
you have and is there ever going to take
advantage of you now the same is true in
the managerial labor market and you know
the people inside your organization a
lot better than the people outside now
you have a problem imagine you're trying
to hire away a top executive from
another company what's inevitably going
to happen is that other companies going
to make a counter off right they
generally don't like the top Executives
to leave but how generous that counter
offer is will depend how much or how
highly they think of that as a person
right how valuable they view that as a
person so as in any standard adverse
selection situation or any situation
where you're trading with somebody who's
got more information about the thing
you're trading here it happens to be an
executive instead of two reasons to go
internally number one they actually do
have skills and knowledge and things
that The Outsiders don't have secondly
well you know them really well and
you're not going to suffer this adverse
selection problem when you steal away
the executive of another company but
let's talk about the bad reasons right
Jonathan alluded to one of them already
you're kind of hiring your buddy to be
honest I don't think that's going on a
lot but I'll give you another flavor of
the same story sort of a different type
of what the academics call an agency
problem the higher my own body thing I'm
pretty sure that happened quite a bit in
the 1970s and 1980s I'm pretty sure that
might still be going on in much smaller
companies large publicly traded
companies 70 80 institutional ownership
the institutional owners breezing down
your neck I really don't think that's
happening very much I mean the outside
directors on these public company boards
they are professionals and this notion
of their old golf buddies and everything
else this may have well been the case
for you 50 years ago I think these days
this is much less of a factor however
think a little bit about the incentives
of the directors on a board I'm
convinced that their incentives are such
that they inevitably will be much more
conservative than they should be
certainly From shareholder's perspective
just think about the downside of hiring
a c yo who doesn't work out the worst
situation for any board member is having
to fire a seal that's just incredibly
painful the weeks and months leading up
to that is an incredible Nightmare and
then once you've done it well now you're
in a new CEO search and you just have a
crisis situation it all happens to
happen very very quickly and keep in
mind this isn't your main job right your
main drop is probably being executive
elsewhere you don't really want to spend
that much time on that company you're
just an outside director the moment you
have to fire a CEO and in haste find a
new one you will be spending a lot of
your time on that company which is
taking you away from your main job so
the downside of hiring the wrong person
is massive it's incredibly painful and
obviously if the person you hire does a
lot of damage to the company there'll
also be a big reputational loss for you
because everybody's going to look at you
and saying well you hired that clown and
that clown ended up destroying billions
or tens of billions of dollars of value
and we have to lay off ten thousand
employees because of him or her so an
absolute night yeah now think about the
upside you're hiring a really really
great CEO okay imagine a great CEO right
now I mean Jack wedge which certainly at
some point everybody thought was the
greatest CEO ever has anybody here
remember who hired Jack Welch
I mean I do see your research and I
really have no idea how you check much
nobody knows so you're not getting a ton
of credit for hiring a superstar
everybody's going to celebrate the
Superstar nobody's going to celebrate
you firing the Superstar and financially
you're not getting that much for the
upside because the typical outside board
directors has a little bit of equity but
frankly it's not very much you probably
don't have any options at all and
compared to your wealth from your main
job it really isn't very much so you're
upside from hiring a great CEO is really
really limited you're downside from
hiring the wrong one is really big it's
painful to hire the wrong one so
inevitably I mean as a finance person
you look at that kind of payoff
structure risk reward profile and you go
well I will rationally be conservative
right I'll rationally be very very
careful my big concern is are the bad
outcomes the left tail of the outcome
distribution I don't want to hire the
really really bad person and then hiring
somebody internally who you already know
really really really well who you know
knows the company knows the culture who
you know is not crazy who you know have
a pretty good idea has not done anything
particularly egregious in the past which
might come out in six months time or 12
months time that takes out a lot of the
left tale of the outcome distribution so
all of that will I think push you
towards being very conservative and
either promoting internally or once you
go outside to go to somebody's
incredibly well-known experience
probably an ex-ceo and as a result also
very expensive
so I think that's sort of the agency
problems that I'm really worried about
so Dirk you already alluded to it a
little bit but I think one last topic
that we should discuss that has received
tons of attention also in the media all
the time is what CEOs get paid and why
and whether we can justify the pay that
we're seeing now there are two
conflicting pieces of evidence I think
that we've discussed right on the one
hand it's very clear that CEOs matter so
I think that piece you said we can
measure that we have experiments that we
can run and we know that they matter a
lot on the other hand this magical
competitive labor market for CEOs where
as a firm you need to be worried that
your CEOs who got hired Away by another
firm as the CEO at an incredibly High
competitive wage doesn't really seem to
be a mechanism that is at play yes so
can you comment a little bit given all
the research that you've done on it on
how is CEO compensation structured and
do you think that people that criticize
Copa for being way too high do they have
a point or do they sometimes have a
point or do you think that it's a pretty
fair compensation schedule that we're
seeing on average across firms the
question you're asking right now is an
incredibly challenging one and one that
we've really been thinking about
personally for 25 years the profession
for 50 or 60 years I don't think we've
got a fully satisfactory answer but let
me try to break it down a little bit let
me start with the simplest point and I'm
going to start by beating up a straw man
because that's always fun when we're
talking about CEOs and some of these S P
500 CEOs at the very top end earn insane
amounts of money in saying not in any
particularly judgmental sense but from
the vantage point of a badly paid
academic those are insane amounts of
money 50 million a year 80 million a
year 100 million a year it's absolutely
stunning and even median pay and the S P
500 is going to be 15 to 20 million a
year right so these are just enormous
amounts of money in response to that one
often hear statements along the lines of
nobody can be worth 10 million 20
million 50 million 100 million a year I
work in the UK these days where pay
levels are lower exactly the same
conversation in fact in a more
aggressive manner it's happening over
here just the numbers are smaller so
nobody can be worth 3 million or 4
million or 5 million or 7 million a year
we don't in any way judge the words of
the person just creates a value that
would justify paying that person 100
million dollars and the reason for that
is simply to scale of these companies
it's as trivial as that the market
capitalization of the largest firms in
the S P 500 so I think the Apple's
Google's Facebook's Microsoft of the
world are all north of a trillion
dollars all right so now all the Board
needs to convince itself of is that
candidate a is going to make the company
one percent more valuable than Company B
one percent of a trillion dollar company
is 10 billion dollars so you're
convinced that candidate a is gonna make
your company worth 10 billion more than
candidate B and now you're competing for
that candidate against another firm or
you're thinking about making that
candidate happy it's easy to justify
paying that person 10 million or 20
million or 30 or 40 or 50 million so
there's no way we can our priority rule
out that those folks aren't worth it's
very easily imaginable that they are but
all right is and you pointed towards
that already there's a really
interesting tension between what we know
about Co hiring right this massive
dominance of insiders it's not a really
liquid Market they're not stealing a
wage other CEOs and how CEO pay is set
so one thing we've done last year was a
really interesting survey of directors
on remuneration Committees of UK
companies so we went to all large
publicly traded companies in the UK we
tried to track down all the directors
they have on the remuneration committee
so the remuneration committee is a
subcommittee of the board of directors
that that's CEO paid so we wanted to
talk to the people who set Co pay and we
asked them and ask us how do you think
about CEO pay how do you set it do you
think it's too high it's too low etc etc
etc and what we found again and that's
was also in the prior literature is an
incredibly High weight an obsession with
the pay of pscos so if you ask a board
of directors what's the big main
determinant of CEO pay is its skill is
it value-added is it they look at you
like you're from Mars and they're not
going to say no no it's what the CEOs in
our peer firms are being paid now notice
there's a tension here right I've just
argued earlier that they are not hiring
each other CEOs away
right they're not really trying to steal
the CEOs of the other firms and they're
not actually worried about their own CEO
being hired away so we asked them out
right oh yeah that makes a lot of sense
to us we're economists it's a labor
market you're worried about peer pay
because you've worried about your Co
being hired away again they look at you
as if you're completely insane and they
have a point and what they're going to
explain to us very slowly in small words
because they think us academics aren't
that bright it's going to say look
the other companies they already have a
CEO and there are only three large
companies in our industry anyway they
all have a seal where do you think our
CEO is going to go they're not trying to
hire our CEO away we're not trying to
hire it and we're like okay okay fair
enough for idiots we acknowledge that
but then why do you care so much about
peer pay how does that fit together and
the answer probably obvious to anybody
working on a board wasn't obvious to us
is because that's what the CEO is using
to assess whether her pay is fair and
that notion of pay fairness very
different from what you alluded to early
right oh isn't it unfair that CEOs are
paid so much what Bots worry about is
not at all I mean maybe a little but not
predominantly that oh CEO pay is 100
times or 300 times or 500 times that of
the median employee what they are really
worried about is that if I pay my CEO
not enough she will look at the pay of
her pscos and go so wait a moment why
doesn't my board appreciate my work am I
not busting my tail end on a daily basis
here am I not working 70 hours a week
have I not achieved and that will lead
to a very very tough situation and a
very tough discussion between the board
and the CEO that boards are actively
trying to avoid so boards have this very
interesting model of ceop psychology
which is that look CEOs are amazing High
Achievers they're really intrinsically
motivated they want to do really well
and it's not about incentive pay or any
such thing but they also really care
about being respected and appreciated
and fairly rewarded so it's almost a
two-step process step one Co looks at
her pay package and decides whether it's
fair or not if it's fair check moving on
and then she's going to work extremely
hard and her intrinsic motivation is
kicking in and she's going to do a great
job and the board still needs to shape
it in the right direction until about
exactly to do and what's expected but
ultimately Now We're Off to the Races
and she's going to work extremely hard
if that first step fails even that first
step she decides wait a moment this is
not fear I'm not being paid as much as
my peers my mates in the other companies
you are in deep trouble you're basically
undermining the intrinsic motivation of
the CEO and at this point you're in a
losing position
thank you so much I think that was one
of the more interesting discussions of
CEO that I've had the pleasure of
listening to in a long time thanks so
much Dirk this was really fantastic
thank you for having me it's been my
pleasure thank you Dirk
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at Apple podcast we'd love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
Next Episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcast for more information and
episodes visit all else equalpodcast.com
or follow us on LinkedIn the ol SQL
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by University FM
[Music]
thank you